So now you've experimented with the die applet. And you've seen how the sampling
distribution changes when we have larger sample sizes. But try one more applet.
This time we have an actual population distribution. Rather than just the values
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and 6. Like we did with the dice. So this time, you can start
with a parent population being normally distributed. Or you can start with a
uniform distribution for the population, or skewed, or custom. You can draw a
bimodal distribution, and then you simulate taking for example, five values from
this population, finding the mean. And graphing it. So I clicked animated here,
and it found five random values from this population, and then plotted the
sample mean. Let's do that same thing 1,000 times. So here's the distribution of
sample means, and you can even calculate the standard deviation of this
distribution, because here we have the population parameters. So the standard
deviation of this distribution should be 7.88, the population standard deviation
divided by the square root of 5. Try it out, do you get 3.54? You probably get
something pretty close, and that might be because this standard deviation is
treating this as a sample, so it's using Bessel's correction. That means that
this standard deviation would be slightly bigger than if we were calculating it.
Treating this as a population. But that's besides the point. Play around with
this. This will really help you get to know sampling distributions. And we're
going to use sampling distributions throughout the rest of the course. The
important thing to take away here is that you can have any population of any
shape. And then, if you plot the distribution of sample means, you'll get a
normal distribution. And it will be more an more normal as n increases. Remember
though if n is 1 then the distribution of means is just going to look like the
population distribution. We don't just need to use computer applet's to
demonstrate the central limit theorem we can use real materials, too. Professors
Laraway and Rogers prepared the following example for you. Check it out.